one suspects that these hoaxers are
simply deranged
but mere mental problems cannot explain
why these incidents seem to have become
more frequent and elaborate in recent
years
it dominated The Establishment media and
what the Liberals love to call our
national conversation always seems more
like a national cacophony to me but they
call it a conversation
one might think that the relative safety
and racial Harmony on college campuses
would be a cause for celebration
but it isn't for liberals because safety
and Harmony and flourishing are not
conducive to drastic social change
they're not conducive to Revolution
so when problems don't exist the
Liberals feel the need to invent them